well MIT is a very different kind of
Institute instead of becoming the
recipients of building industry culture
we can now change building industry by
the kinds of experiments we're doing in
school MIT has a variety of departments
that are so powerful that they have the
potential of radicalizing what we do in
design and in the architecture
department even the way that we've
structured our curriculum around
workshops and other kinds of
collaborations we foster and encourage
this kind of cross-disciplinary platform
so you're situated perfectly for the
kinds of things that only MIT can do
the invention of human artifacts of any
kind always consists of three elements
the geometry the process and the
material that constitute that artifact
it's very clear that new materials
engender new forms and architectural
design benefits from addressing applying
new materials in an informed way the
emergent materials group and the urban
metabolism group share a central
interest in materials for the built
environment lately we've been working
great deal in the area of foam -
materials especially foam cements and
concrete's so typically a beam in
bending is going to have the greatest
amount of stresses on the top and bottom
so we can reduce the amount of material
on the interior of a beam
the worker Lee tries to address that
there's two main paradigms throughout
almost every industry one paradigm is
what can you design what can you compute
or analyze and the other paradigm is
what can you physically construct or
what can you build the work really tries
to traverse all scale lengths it tries
to work from the nano scale which is
traditionally where we see self-assembly
and biological examples chemical
examples and it tries to bridge that and
say can't we use this phenomenon a
self-assembly as an new paradigm for
building things at large scale we work
with any type of material synthetic or
natural materials and really try to
design specific geometries that have
materials in mind and when you design
those two together they can respond to
energy and the energy sources can be
heat shaking gravity pneumatics
electronics so you can use any type of
energy when you mix that with the
geometry and material properties then
they can respond and they can change
state primarily it will first be applied
in extreme environments scenarios where
it's difficult to build
the research and the practice is really
about cross-disciplinary collaborations
between designers scientists engineers
working on this phenomenon self-assembly
discovering where we find it naturally
where we can use it synthetically and
trying to apply that at all different
scale in
the focus of our work at least at this
smaller scale of the at the scale of say
art installations or
retail we leverage CNC fabrication
methods but not as a way to exude their
prowess necessarily but more as a way to
help us get at a particular formal
agenda
we have installation called totems which
in a way is a kind of proto architecture
not quite architectural not quite
sculptural but I think that it offers a
kind of proposition to each of those
disciplines we do a lot of testing via
3d prints a lot of the formal
investigations for totem specifically
happened in 3d prints we we did maybe 30
to 50 3d prints of the totems as a way
to understand how the light and shadows
were working and how best the anamorphic
effects were working before we went to
the large-format
wire cutter in terms of collaborations
some of those happen here at MIT
Joel Amir and I are developing an
installation now which is an anechoic
chamber and the anechoic chamber uses
industrial felt both on its exterior and
as a way to absorb sound on the interior
I'm bringing a kind of disciplinary or
formal or geometric interest on the one
hand also a certain set of specialized
understandings of the behavior of the
sheet materials on the other so my
architectural interests are really broad
but in terms of my current research
preoccupation it's about material
geometry specifically sheet shapes or
sheet material geometries how they Bend
stretch stack fold but obviously
understanding sheet materials is really
critical to Architecture this is sort of
a long-standing discourse on sheet
materials in architecture in part
because it's so ubiquitous and
conventional construction so everything
including plywood sheet metal steel
aluminum plastics all of these have to
deal with the developable surface
geometries which is to say sheet shapes
generally and so expanding the the total
set of understandings about sheet shades
is a totally enough kind of obviously
worthwhile architectural undertaking
these installations attempt to go jump
from the scale of the paper model to you
know the scale of the architectural
space at the very least
well over the past 20 years first as
office da now as nada we've identified
two or three areas of focus the first
has been to look at materials and their
behavior as a point of departure for
many of the architectural experiments we
do the second area is to recognize that
materials don't have an endless limit
everything comes in modules and sheets
in blocks in bricks and that without
aggregation there's no way of beginning
to figure out how construction works in
general so the detail of bringing things
together as a point of departure has
been another central focus so this has
been a kind of point of revolution for a
range of projects that we researched and
undertaken some of which are at the
scale of a piece of furniture others
that are at the scale of a building and
others that are really at the scale of
urbanism
one of the agendas of the studio is to
create interactive architectures for
public space through design and
technology and these projects can range
in scale from the scale of the body such
as the defensible dress project which is
a wearable architecture which uses a
microcontroller and shape memory alloys
to defend your personal space to very
public scale infrastructural projects it
is our proposal for the Audi urban
features initiative where we're
speculating on high-speed regional
infrastructure and transformations in
the city around issues of mobility for
the year 2030 it seems now more and more
necessary that our environments have to
become smarter
more responsive and more flexible the
way in which architecture is made needs
to be completely rethought if we're to
go beyond bricks and mortar to engage
the challenges of the next century
my work as an architect focuses on
designing architecture and urban scale
interventions that engage the emergent
infrastructure of our time we're
interested in how design engages that
mutability between energy and matter
when materials generate energy or store
it when materials are dynamic and change
state exchange heat produce light or
communicate information the challenge I
think for the discipline of architecture
today isn't in digital fabrication it's
in material fabrication in thinking
about what it means to be material today
when we move fluidly between digital and
physical realms how we use materials and
not waste them and how we form materials
and how we transport them
if we're going to change the building
industry and regenerate an innovation
based manufacturing segment in the
United States then I think we need to do
this from within practice from working
with the norms of the building industry
but not settling for those norms instead
innovating to both accept and transform
those standard conditions
I think we're pursuing several
initiatives relating with computation
material at several different areas
dynamic interactivity as one with
hypersurface
and we're driving that forward imagining
actively a low plastic environments if
you like it's a demonstration of the
power of computation come real time then
in the robotic manufacturing work we're
looking for how information and material
all coming together with control
directly at the architects workplace so
we're developing tools that allow
architects within their native software
my trainer to pilot a powerful
production machine like a cooker robot
demonstrating I think what will be the
future of manufacturing which is
sophisticated algorithms and modeling
that link directly to sophisticated
manufacturing machines and allow both
new efficiencies but new versatility new
formal complexities I'm also frustrated
by the slowness of the building industry
to innovate materially as fantastically
a fantastic amount of research in
material science that's pent up and it's
just dying to come at a period where
these sort of environmental concerns are
becoming so enormous
the challenge of building the developing
world is so so extraordinary that
unnecessary cad/cam meets material
science like composites I think is is
going to breathe all new
new life into into the architectural
building in the streets
you